un marché pays placée sous le signe de
la saint valentin
le département a mis les agriculteurs à
contribution cette veille de la fête des
amoureux des fleurs orchidées roses mais
également des fruits et légumes pour
préparer un repas en amoureux
les producteurs pays ont sorti leurs
plus beaux étals pour montrer leur
savoir faire
balaj et plus de tous les fruits et
légumes là j'ai pris des bras j'ai pour
faire un bon massa les pommes de terre
et bon ben c'est bien mais si ça pouvait
faire renouveler tout le temps oui ça
serait chouette lui donc on a dès
l'achat directement avec les
les planteurs c'est excellent le jardin
de l'état un endroit que les producteurs
connaissent désormais l'occasion pour
eux de rencontrer les consommateurs et
d'échanger avec eux c'est surtout
important aussi d'avoir le contact
direct puisque les gens ils me posent
des questions comment se planter
escabeau voyez comment c'est fait est-ce
qu'on mettait beaucoup d'insecticides et
tout ça on réexplique est effrayant la
qualité et fraîcheur et la qualité la
fraîcheur
donc voyez vous-même contiennent bonnes
sessions de nice on n'a pas ça me permet
de vendre mes produits oui c'est pour le
consommateur c'est une bonne chose parce
que si je sais pas si vous avez les
primaires dans les compétitif et les
réunionnais veulent consommer pays
savoir ce qu'ils mettent dans leur
assiette
à l'image de nabila qui outre le prix
cherche avant tout la qualité du produit
lorsqu'on tient debout oui en terme de
prix bien sûr c'est pour ça que dément
mais surtout plusieurs variétés de
mangues à des prix imbattables
oui c'est ça fait moins cher sinon nous
sommes un pêcheur sur la fin et puis
avait appris depuis
donc vous avez éléments d'américains se
trouve à trois euros le kilo
vous avez des deux est à un héros 53 kg
frais 4 euros
les ied hissé à 4 euros la mangue menacé
après l'occasion de discuter de mieux
comprendre les techniques de production
comme ici avec le mec génial
sans rien à fêter il est devenu il était
comme ça au départ je vais pas jouer pas
vous dire mais un marché pays qui a
côtoyé un marché artisanal l'occasion de
découvrir des objets de trouver des
idées cadeaux pour offrir à son amoureux
c'est important parce que justement là
pour la saint-valentin fête ça permet
aux gens donc au public et de faire des
cadeaux valorisant l'artisanat local et
c'est vrai qu'on a le choix au niveau
des boues des bijoux et tout ce qui est
gastronomie aussi donc les confitures
on peut on peut vraiment faire
plein de cadeaux différents originaux et
en plus ça ça met en valeur toute
l'économie locale est ce important
rendez vous pour les retardataires à
l'espace régler le mois prochain pour le
traditionnel marché pays du département